Oh my god.
Smash that bell to get notifications of when we go live.
Smash that bell to get smashed.
To get smashed?
Yeah.
Yeah, like with alcohol or something.
Yeah, I am.
Not literally.
I can't help myself.
She loves smashing.
No Nigel Thornberry.
She just says smashing.
Are we here?
Okay, finally.
We're here. I'm sorry for the mess.
Yeah, we're here.
I'm live now. Finally, dead game.
Okay.
We, a viewer, have done the holistic approach where none of us will mute.
So, you're just going to hear everything all at once.
Yeah, that's how we're all.
It just as a reminder, all donations,
more memberships or super chats will be addressed at the end of the stream
when it's not an absolute cluster buck of all six of us together.
But yes, the whole premise of the power washer was I was going to do a gag
and be like, oh, Viola isn't doing so well.
We might go bust.
We might go and put a bikini on and get clean in.
Well, that idea is out the window now.
So instead we're playing Gartik phone.
I've never played it personally.
She be suggested it and I, her word is law.
So let's just take it away.
I'm taking over the company.
Shadow CEO.
Okay. Do you guys want to start? You ready?
Yeah.
We can finally do it.
I know cheating.
The guy is so chat.
Don't fucking cheat.
Don't fucking do it.
I swear it off.
How long do I have to do the sentence?
I don't know.
Help me out.
Senpai.
Don't give away until it's over.
This is our secret.
Senpai.
This is funny.
Peek comedy.
I don't think so actually.
I know what that is.
So let me change it.
Hello?
What's wrong?
Moshi Moshi.
Okay.
We have to draw these now.
Oh my god.
I'm drawing this with a mouse.
You broke that.
I can't see.
Don't cheat.
This is so bad.
Oh no.
I've never done this before.
Wait.
Can I make my pen smaller or is she?
Oh no.
Why is he getting drunk?
Why am I drunk?
I don't even know what's happening.
Why are you guys screaming?
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
How much time is left in my god?
The top right corner is the indicator.
Not the shading.
I'm an artist.
I'm such an artist.
Oh yeah.
Wait.
All you can fucking draw is me.
You're all done.
No.
Wait.
I can look up with a mouse.
We need to get a witness pen.
Hold on.
I can't spell.
What the fuck am I doing?
What am I doing with that line?
I should whip out my drawing tablet.
It's beautiful.
Better with a mouse.
No.
It's better with a mouse if it looks like hot garbage.
It looks great.
Hey.
Would you?
I'm done.
What's Tech say?
I can't tell you.
Oh, where are you going?
These are your items.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
100% Wood.
Wood.
Why not?
Well, this is the chat logs.
Oh my god.
We need to put the chat logs in quick.
Oh, good answer.
Chat logs?
Little person.
Why?
You guys aren't ready for mine?
Let's put a bit of detail.
We need some wood detail.
Americans always have an eagle.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
What's his name?
There we go.
There you go.
What do you think?
Wait, is that an art?
Tilly.
My gen mates are wild.
Oh my god.
I don't know what he looks like.
Oh no.
Oh god.
Hold on.
Wait, is she decent so far away?
All right.
I don't know what Thorne Berry looks like.
I had to look it up.
I'm just guessing.
I'm just going for it.
Why is?
I'll look like this.
Wait, I don't look like that.
Sugar.
Don't question this.
How do you draw?
I hate you.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't see on you.
I don't know.
I don't know how to draw.
I don't know how to draw anymore.
That's pretty good, right?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
This is something.
Wait, hold on.
Ginger in it and there you go.
That's me.
I don't know what.
This is awful.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
Let's draw some hair.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
Draw his horn.
Don't ask questions so far.
That is very nice.
I don't know.
My little leaflings are saying I'm a tree.
Wait, wait, no.
Emi's hair is not orange.
Is it?
Emi's ginger.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm ginger?
You're not.
Really?
I'm a strawberry blonde.
Is this the right OG sign?
I had my image.
What does that even say?
Oh, meow.
Oh my god.
Which one of you speaks Spanish?
I'm 100% sure this is an OG sign.
Oh lord.
Atashi?
What?
Oh, how am I supposed to draw that?
Did we even have one?
What do I look like?
Oh wait, I can't even draw the fucking toilet.
What do I even look like?
This is terrible, Unmouse.
Wait, pits is not feet.
Pits is armpits.
We're grabbing onto the ground for dear life.
Right, armpits.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Because none of you guys know some English phrases
or some joking phrases.
What I'm hearing is that a lot of you guys are misinterpreting
whatever it is that's very funny.
It's going all over his back.
It's not looking good.
How do you draw an angry mouth?
Oh, there we go.
Pits is feet.
No, I'm pretty sure it's armpits.
We need to draw.
Pits is sweat.
This is amazing.
What does the Walmart logo look like?
Your armpits has become sentience.
Walmart.
I'm not even going to explain to Mercy.
Oh wait, don't you toilet stuff like that?
Oh wait.
Hold on.
I don't know.
It does make it better.
It makes it worse.
I thought pits is like pits.
This is so fucking funny.
I think that works out.
There we go.
The radiation.
I can't wait to see everything.
Radiation.
Oh no, wait, no, we'll get to see everything.
No, we'll get to see everything.
Oh my god.
I'll do manual.
There's going to be no voiceover.
And then we'll be beginning from the end.
Okay, let's see.
So I said, I see with Nidals Thornberry's face saying smashing.
Immigrant.
What's going on?
No!
You look awesome!
What's going on?
Is that Aisey누h reputation?
Is that Aisey Galaxyần revolutionary?
It was!
Oh no!
Why does he look all handsome?
Oh boy.
Oh.
You're on there.
She wanted it.
And then there's Chris Hansen.
Oh my gosh.
And I said, she said it's going to kill me with a crash.
You know, date luck.
Oh no.
It's great to deal.
Oh my god.
I love it.
It actually worked out.
Why is it trying my best?
Why does it always sound such a fat talk?
There's a pee pee.
Because he loves me and he's big.
They grew up together.
They grew six times that day.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
It is feet.
I don't like how her feet is actual teeth.
I know.
I like that.
I never wrote stinky peats.
Which is feet.
But like.
And then she drew pits.
I drew myself in an armpit.
Because I thought it was.
So it was feet.
And not armpits.
She's screaming so loud.
Sorry.
The spot is over.
Okay.
I got it from AC.
Very good artist.
Don't ask me what this is.
What does that even mean?
When your job is a poo.
So when your poo hits your prostate on the way out.
Oh I thought it was Javi.
Javi's a poo.
I draw this.
You see me sucking?
I mean suckers don't live hot too.
Oh wait.
Is she giving a blow job?
That's what it looks like.
That's what it looks like to me.
Oh my gosh.
I love the drill.
This is so fucking good.
Oh boy.
It's over.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
That's cute.
I love that.
Oh it's not a cat.
It's not a cat.
It's a winky face.
Okay it's a winky face.
I was like what is miawa?
So I was like who is this guy?
We are so good.
This is a cat.
That's good.
I love that.
Okay this makes sense.
This makes sense of what on earth we were drawing.
Because I just chucked out
and like that's items on the shelves.
I worked around.
Oh this is a good diaper.
I see understood me.
Oh my god.
I snored in my teeth or my nose.
It's painful it hurts.
I can't.
I had to do the toilet stall gap.
Because that's all I see about
when I see American memes.
Oh the toilet stall.
The toilet gap is so big.
You can literally look at people's eyes through it.
It went the wrong way.
Oh no.
We have them closed because you know it's a private time
and you're very vulnerable taking a big job.
So yeah it's actually closed everywhere else in the planet.
Oh you're so lucky.
Yeah.
I had people peeking at me in high school
through the stalls and I'm like
me too.
Oh no.
Is there a DC?
Is there a check?
Is there a DC check?
Are you in the lobby?
Do you need to reload the lobby?
It's gonna do it on its own usually.
No I'm gone.
The link should be in the discord.
Don't show your fucking screen on the discord.
They'll see everything.
I see all of our naughty photos
we just send to each other.
It's real.
It's mostly memes.
It's weird.
Any memes?
I mean to be fair we did share
on that page.
We did share some
lucky nudes of ours.
They've seen my titties.
I started roleplaying as the girls
with my nudes so I was like
this is what Evie would do.
This is what Evie would do.
Our discord is so chaotic.
Okay.
Real though.
But also I did snort out
my tea.
It went down the wrong hole and went up my nose.
Oh no.
There's your snort and tea.
This is what you hate to talk about.
It's a stosterone.
It hurts so much.
Yeah.
I'm getting
pain.
I push
my ears.
I'm getting another heart beat
right now every time she talks.
Oh no.
Our nudes are eye-prone nudes.
I'm not a man.
And my face turned out like that.
Oopsie.
How does she talk like this?
I don't know.
Oopsie.
I feel like Azera
can do a really good Jennifer Coolidge impression.
Me too.
Jennifer Coolidge.
Did it.
I don't know what Jennifer Coolidge
is impression.
Wait you don't know Jennifer Coolidge.
Jennifer Coolidge.
Oh.
I'm going to switch back to you.
Oh my god.
Jennifer Coolidge.
Are you kidding me?
Why are we opening our gap for the way
you raise your voice?
Azura.
Click that link in the general
discord to bring me out.
Is it not letting you back in?
Are you being funny?
No.
Are you kidding me?
I don't hear you screaming.
Your make cuts out.
Azura.
So it just goes
What's happening?
It's constantly loading.
Did you?
No.
Can we do another?
I'm sorry.
Will you guys see the discord if I open it?
No.
I'm sorry.
I should see anything else.
I would close the winner capture
in the OBS just in case.
Yes, you can open it.
Are we restarting a new lobby?
A new lobby?
I think we can still invite to this lobby.
A bit of all.
Why is there two?
Are we going to a different room?
I don't know.
I only see one of you.
No.
Wait, there's a new one?
No, there's Azura again.
We're good.
We're Gucci.
Okay, which one should we play?
Normal.
Knock off.
Keep yourself focused.
Try to replicate the drawings while the clock gets faster.
Create animations in a collaborative way.
Icebreaker.
Play with a sentence.
Exquisite co-ops.
This character is connected by the top of the drawings.
I don't know what that means.
Hold on.
Complement.
Complete the sketch.
Start with basic lines and see other players' interpretations.
Masterpiece.
Create a piece of art.
Play in a single term with no time limit.
I feel like story would be funny.
Write a narrative using only the previous sentence.
Yes, okay.
You want to do story?
Yeah, let's try story.
Start writing.
Start.
Oh.
Wait, do I have to write a full story or just a sentence?
Just a sentence.
Okay, okay.
Do you like write the whole story or no?
No, you have really limited characters.
I don't know it.
No.
What did you do?
There's time.
15 seconds, love.
Oh, my God.
I wanted to write more.
You can only write one sentence.
Okay.
Done.
The end.
There's it.
Oh.
We are not beating the caca allegations.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, they're going to know this is me spelling it
because I didn't use a Z on that.
I'm just going to leave it like that.
Yep, I'm sending it.
I'm not even spell checking.
Fuck it.
I'm bad at stories.
What the fuck?
So they...
Oh.
Oh, the sentence is so small.
Like, I want to give a bit more.
Me, too.
Wait.
I think it gets shorter over time.
I'm going to be like,
I'm going to write until, fuck.
What?
What's that?
Okay.
Wow.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
I'm not a spell neighboring.
Oh, fuck.
Her name.
It's funny because...
Yes.
Nobody's the snippet.
The pen pals.
The bleeding hearts and the harem
all get to see this unfold.
And we're all just vaping like...
Oh.
Fuck it.
Oh, you...
Wait, is that the fucking...
Soft and warm.
Fancy little bowl of fur.
Happy kitty.
Sleepy kitty.
You watch fucking
big bang
steering.
Wait, that's a nice spell.
I need more letters.
I am...
Amazing.
I'm an amazing writer.
That sounds like she me.
No.
I don't know this lyrics.
This...
This agency...
We can just...
I hate this.
They don't give you enough to write.
It's like...
Fuck off.
Okay.
Here's how terrible this is going to be.
I'll do the auto.
This is terrible.
How about everybody reads their own story?
Yeah, of course.
Okay.
In a galaxy far, far away
there was a goat with big titties.
She had so much milkers
and started raining milk.
Milk.
Azara then went on to make
an empire be milk daily.
It was so successful
the neighboring kingdoms became jealous.
They also wanted some of the juice.
Ew, cooties are not good.
You're not good.
Oh, boy.
Okay, long time ago
there was a polar bear princess
who was trying to fit into...
They're a little bit stronger
than any foreign addiction.
They couldn't touch it.
No, that was from Drake.
I didn't know how to finish it.
I was like...
Ding ding.
That was supposed to be the song like ding ding.
I was so hard.
I'm crying.
There was a beach of agency
that was lived.
They all came in
and the children were just that bad.
So they danced, the pee-pee dance
and told the kids.
And then finally,
they peed everywhere on the
floor, the walls, the bed,
the kite.
We're all filled with piss everywhere
but he loved it.
The fact that he was in a piss prompt
before AC came out with that
literally wasn't used.
AC didn't have one.
Third.
Seventh character added.
This is so good.
Okay.
Once upon a time, there were whores.
They were the elitists of whores.
Wild West.
All these really cute cowgirls.
Pussycat.
So cute.
So messy.
Big bang theory. More like bang bang.
Your mom left.
Keep my mom out of your head now.
I'm sorry.
Ten.
Once upon a time, there was a big bump.
Oh, no.
They all took mine.
She was trying to grab it.
She was trying to grab mine.
Seriously.
My gosh.
She was trying to grab mine.
You can't stop thinking
What's the fun?
You guys know why I rate the scripts
Why do we keep talking about shit all of that?
She became so bad, I hate this.
Fuck no.
No, I didn't want to be pregnant by Sonic.
Azura, do you have a mic filter on?
I can never hear you.
Turn that mic.
Get that steel-
See that steel-series.
No, it's not.
Don't have a filter on.
There's no filter on?
No, there's no filter on.
Your steel-series filter.
I don't have a filter.
I don't have one on.
What is happening?
Can't wait for the void if we survive.
That'll be fine.
Why don't we try another one?
Another, another, another.
Please, please, no more shit.
No more shit in his.
No promises.
I'll try my best.
Can we do a compliment?
My stomach hurts.
All the actions are a mystery.
You can't hear Mercy, Mercy test?
Sorry, sorry.
I was muting because I was coughing
because I was laughing.
My side hurts so badly.
Okay, Mercy test complete.
Do you want to do a compliment?
We draw on each other's drawings, basically.
Oh, we should try that.
I think that would be fun.
I can't wait to draw some of this.
Some basic lines, okay.
So sketch some basic lines, okay.
Let me do this.
Maybe I could just, maybe I would do like some basic lines.
Like woo.
Okay, boom.
Boom.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna draw a bunch of dicks.
I just leave that.
To castle.
No.
Are you joking?
These are blockers.
You know exactly what you did.
And no, I don't have the strength to resist.
What?
Wait, wait, wait.
I got it, I can make this.
I can salvage this.
This is the back legs of it.
Uh-huh.
This is huge milkers.
And then this, this is legs.
There you go.
Only a few more lines.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, you're so dark.
You're so creepy.
Honestly.
I'll get the girl to tell you off if you don't behave.
That's shocking.
You guys don't have innocent eyes anymore.
Why?
Cute.
It's all rude to me.
Cute little girl.
Wait, am I supposed to finish this off?
Are we supposed to finish it off?
I think so, because it's given us tons of time.
Hold on.
Oh, okay.
I fixed it.
Oh, oh.
a big fish up bra.
Oh, my God, I've just finished it.
What the hell?
It's my name.
Oh, wait, that's not a thing?
Oh, no, that looks like...
Dang it.
Just give me the pencil.
There you go.
I saved it.
they give you a lot more time for the yeah you're to finish it you're to finish
it you need to finish okay I'm fucking stupid okay so I'm I don't worry saved
it save it girl let's let's get some nice shading in to make this look extra
wow
yeah so beautiful
I saved it
they prank him
I think this is the best I got maybe a bit of fluff on Mateo
oh wait
who drew a pair of hairy ballsack
what
oh these are all
oh I really know what I want to do but I know I shouldn't do it because we're on YouTube
I'm fixing this
uh oh no
I can't I can't think of one thing
this is amazing
oh wait maybe hold on hold on I got it I got it I got it I got it
fuck how do I go back okay
oh fuck what is this?
they've got a big head
wow
oh I've drawn them too
this is so fucking good
there we go
fucking go
I'm like trying so hard right now I can't even think of anything to say I'm like trying so hard
oh my gosh use your imagination
use your imagination
there you go
look at you all
I'm so proud of you
I'm like
alright we need to be nice to the other side
your laugh is so cute I see
thank you
I love you so much
oh the best of me
that was great for you
really well
yeah it's a water bottle
I'm gonna fill in the eye
that's the best I go
quick quick quick quick
I saved the pair of ball sacks
oh wait you can't get into it
there we go
senpai can you do better
shut the fuck up
I love when you do that
I got the hairy ball sacks
hold on give me a second
you're asking me not to draw vaginal
oh my god re-filling
what do I do
why can't I do it
what do I do here
how do I save this
I need to do this all for memory
okay I won't draw that
cause that would be
oh my god I just realized
the mercies snippets
like fucking grogu
from star wars
oh wait no it was a hard one
I saved it
women were less immature than men
you're wrong
I was gonna draw a kuchi
or a woman giving birth but I'm not gonna
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
I literally don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now
there we go
wait hold on
oh my god I have time
one two three
these are supposed to be light ones
pen pals
I'm running out of time
oh my god this is
okay and then volcano
these are light ones
do do do do
oh I'm trying
I got it
what's one of those
even light ones
oh god refills
refills how could I forget
I saved it I saved it
this is the best I got
I ain't got none other than me
this is a really specific reference
and I don't know if you're gonna get it
but there used to be a
flash game where your guy was on
like a snowboard
I love that game
someone just drawn that
literally this is perfect
that's my drawing
someone says lane raider
oh is that what it's called
it's called
what is bear pantsu
panties
I don't know what a whale looks like
I remember fancy pants
because he had big old pants
that were fancy
yeah you know the story
you know the story
I might make that up
I
you know the story
did he have a beard? I don't know
I drew something
I don't know
I don't know how to do that though
can I zoom in
yeah
bear braid
braid is pants
wait they don't have pins
fuck it
no fuck
I didn't mean to add that
you drew ball sacks everywhere
it's not you sheebie
no I didn't draw a ball sack
I got it
wait
who's whispering
what
there is whispering some like
evil incantations
that's it
wait no that's not nice
this is all a C right now
and I'm not even going to pretend otherwise
it was definitely Azura that drew the ball sack
100%
why do I feel like this is a lie
no I didn't draw it
I'm really drawing over it right now
if you guys didn't know
Azura's ears actually have
gold jewelry on the end of them
this is nice
she's pimped out with jewelry
but it's like not a vanity
there you go
it's like gifts
isn't cheating to erase
isn't it cute
so if you didn't know when a women
when a women lactate
well how
oh my god
through the fabric
so they'll be like a piece of gold
I know this isn't Azura's
that's cool
that looks terrible get rid of that
oh my god you can't just control Z it
my life
I was trying to talk about lactation though
this is yeah it was right before she said chocolate
that was correct
what the fuck
milk
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face
nah they have some titties mate
it's all I can see
I have saved
I have single-handedly saved
the stream probably
this is supposed to be the liquid
the liquid
wait this is fine
that's cheating I know what I wanted to draw
that's nothing
fine I didn't know what to draw for my own drawing
fine
I started it
and I'm gonna finish it
it's me
looking fucking mental
I don't know
I'm already pooped from this
it's the old
it's the old Mac okay
okay
I would talk about it
it takes too much brain power
to do this and poop
it's your little
yeah
stop
pretty good
I think I did a great job
uh
are you winning son
yeah
is it the amazon
oh my god
is it the reverse amazon position
when the girls
what are you talking about
reverse amazon
you mean like ebay
yeah
that's definitely what she's talking about
can they break it
oh
okay
okay let's see our albums
oh boy
okay
anybody need to take a quick break before
I'm ready
let's do this
that was yours
okay okay
are those worms
oh my god
oh that's cute
okay
that's cute
oh
yeah
oh that's so good
the snack is cute
what do you mean you're a bad artist
that's a very good little bear
that's good
he got owner under the blanket and everything
oh yeah
look at that
oh it is the Arthur rule
beautiful
uh
okay
what else could I draw for this
oh
okay
uh
sherry
oh
I like
I do deserve milkers
open that
open now
okay
wait
when I said I saved them
I lied
I didn't save the stream at all
I was
if I don't see a snail
believe it
oh shit
oh my god
oh that's so cute
that's so cute
I love
I love replays
oh my god that's so cute
no
that's funny
and then there's
I was like give me
give me
oh my god
oh
no
that's so cute
yeah that was cute
oh
that's so cute
I drew me in love with
oh
oh that's so cute
literally me
that's me
no
that is mine
oh my god
he's so bad
I can't show that
I see
we'll do it me and the boys
okay okay
oh my god
why the mono bro
wait
why are you guys
oh my god
I was like oh this is like
lane raider
oh
that's so cute
that's really cute I love that
and me
oh that's cute
I knew it
I knew it was you
llama chuba for gentoo
oh wait
that's a good one and then they saw the thing on the right
oh
that's cute mercy
that's a good rabbit
and a bicycle
I was learning how to ride a bike
oh
stop
this one ended up being
the most innocent
this is what it's like to be in vlr
I'm giving birth
icebreakers
icebreakers kind of boring
oh
why don't we do it
I'll cancel it
icebreakers kind of boring
icebreakers boring
yeah it's boring
can I cancel it
if you want
okay how do we cancel
wait are we doing this or are we canceling it
I don't know
how do we cancel it
what is happening
oh there's a fucking ad
I'm just making another room
okay
alright
where's my
carry to that
and you guys can see John Snow and Sansa start
this is the stream
wait put me back in
they still advertise
wait so do we have a name
lobby
yeah it says one of seven
wait what is happening
I don't know what is happening
okay let's just play this
it's not the greatest but we can just play it
is everyone in this lobby
are we in your new lobby
do we have a new lobby or not
somebody else make it
because I made a new one
I was trying to make a new one
everyone hide the asset
hide the game
the garlic phone window
hide it first and then someone make a new one
I can't make it because my connections don't
I'll do it
okay
see Emmy proven what a big girl she is
that was so fucking weird I'm sorry
so fucking creepy
I'm so sorry thank god
I'm sorry it's so
it's so chaotic
I don't know why there's two of me on screen
when I hide up
I hate that
so we are opening in your lobby
yeah
show us a link in the discord
you can hate
I said
okay understood
leave page
big stronzo
let me open the link
oh there we go nice and easy
I've got a pasha
can you check
is everyone here
no I'm here
yeah we're here
okay which one do you want to play
knockoff is fun
because it's like
super
try to replicate the drawing
oh yeah do knockoff
that looks good
because you make it pretty drawing
and then it becomes hell
why are we supposed to draw
anything you want
anything
anything no no wait
not you not you
maybe not anything for you
shit
give us something I'm being put on the spot
my mains going blank
okay hold on let me draw
let me draw
I'll draw
I'm taking off the blindfold you're fine now
I'll draw shibi
yeah
should we all just like draw somebody
no I'm joking
I was like oh I'm kind of locked in
sorry sorry
I've decided to draw one of us
that I have already said out loud
I don't know what to draw
guys give me an idea
don't put me on the spot
don't put me on the spot I don't know
I don't even know what to draw
I'm just going to draw one of you guys
so I'm going to choose
on the spot
you want me to draw that
oh this is terrible
on a mouse
that one's sexy
funny
oh
how much time do we have
I'm like can I draw the whole gang again
you have quite a bit of time
with this one
okay hold on
we're going to draw the whole gang with this
oh that does not hurt
the berries look
da da da da da da da
da da da da
oh no no
oh
how the fuck do you draw something sitting down
oh my god I'm having a stroke
they're not the good kind
what on earth
there's a good kind
that's supposed to be a snow berry
well this is close enough
I'm going to be an up guy
I always say after this
oh my god
I want to draw harmony
I want to draw your name
I can't draw
like this
it has kind of like
who's next
we need to draw the devilish hat
fuck this is hot cause like I don't know
what to fucking draw
get creative nerds jeez
get creative
okay miss artist
okay
I don't know
Emi comes out
Emi's like I'm just going to draw myself casual
and it comes out with like this fucking banger of a commission
it would probably cost like $500
to do
she like bangs that out and I'm like
oh my god
I'm going to make a vtuber
model
don't ask me what
I wish I could
wish I had a pink
a figurative talent
speaking of that
they were like
thank you for not tying down your talents
to the designs that you assigned them
and they can be more themselves
and I'm like yeah well
why would I do that
I was like I don't know why
I feel like it's such a basic thing
what the fuck do I need to draw now
a bleeding heart
I tried my best
literally I have
literally
oh someone rated the vtuber
they were like the only thing that would have been
it better as if
you let them design their models
from the start I'm like bruv
it took me a fucking year to get here
oh my god
it takes forever to
it is not like an overnight thing
draw and rank a vtuber model
honestly who am I missing
she knows how to do it
the lot of work
oh my god
there's only a select few corpos that will let you do that
literally it takes a little long
oh shit
man this is rough
usually ones that have like artists in house as well
yeah we don't
we just put in the coin part
most companies
if not all of them
say for you
will have
pre-made
so it's not actually standard
for people to choose
it's really not
that's why it's usually like
cast for the roles
you have to fit the characters
everything for
no
there
what the fuck
is that
it looks like an abomination
oh
memorize it and replicate it
this is easy
what is this
look how cute this is
okay
now we have to draw it
are we ready
just draw it your way
and that's the fun part
I've already forgot which position everyone was in
wrong
this is so bad
sorry reflinx honestly I would talk more
but this takes so much brain power
to do this
I'm so brain dead
like I'm
I'm reading chat
I'm reading everything but I'm not
responding I'm so sorry
I can see everyone
saying
I'm just really in this
I can't remember
who was where
I'm just fucking losing it
I think
oh boy
I forgot there was a shorter time
what the fuck
that's far too short
this is why it's chaotic
why was the other one longer
I don't remember what
I didn't want to do that
oh
okay okay okay
okay
oh shit there's like no time
we draw this as fast
as we can
oh fuck
oh
no no no
not like this
I can't remember what it looked like
is there supposed to be someone
in a pirate boat by the way
cause I don't think I saw it
is there supposed to be a person in it
I don't know
the timer is supposed
to go really fast
so it's
oh my god
okay that's easy enough
that's easy enough
oh it's already half
okay
gotta go fast
faster faster oh fuck
faster faster
oh my god
I am so sorry
oh
fast
okay
oh hey it's me
why is it no black
oh I don't know
okay okay okay we can do this
we can do this
okay okay okay
let's go let's go let's go
don't panic don't panic
the greatest part is that
we are all panicking
oh no no no
wait
wait a minute
what is this
what even is this
okay this is easy
this has to be
this has to be men's
easy
was it blue I can't remember it was blue
let's fucking go
this looks like shade but oh wow
whoa
I mean
that was rough
oh my god
that was easy really
that's amazing
I love it
oh
you have all the time
why didn't you give me time
I did not have
any time for this
I was like
at least
at least it stayed a cat
that little campfire with all of us together
that's so fucking cute
that's what I hate most
we don't have time
we're doing a slack of face
oh we're all here in room 5
Okay, this is good this stage
oh she's not in jail she's at the
king
Okay, that looks like it.
Oh my God.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
She broke her tail by the end.
She broke it.
He's freeing it.
Wow.
Oh, so close.
One piece.
I was like, why the...
I was like, what was the thing in the bowl?
I was like...
I was like, stop.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
She's getting ugly.
She's getting all the water.
Oh, my God.
It looks like a floating fish.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
She's shooting her piss.
She's shooting her piss?
Wait, that's supposed to be me.
What?
You're giving her rest.
Oh, my goodness.
It needs to survive.
Before we bite him.
Oh.
The piss is gone.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was so good.
That was so good, right?
One more.
What have we not done?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
All the actions are mystery.
Drawing and sentences are hitting during the game.
What's the secret?
The secret seems rough.
I've never done that one before.
Okay.
We'll try it.
Last round, boys.
Last round.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, shoot.
What?
Oh, it's a secret.
How else does it know what I'm writing?
Wait, what?
Huh?
Yeah!
It's a secret to everyone.
Oh, bro.
I can't erase my things.
I don't know.
What is this?
Um...
Why is this?
Oh!
The lines disappear too!
It just appears.
Oh, we can't see what we're drawing?
What?
Okay, I'll draw fast.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I don't know. I think...
I'm going to just guess...
what it is.
Where it is?
That's so funny.
Oh, god.
What the fuck?
Oh, no, no.
I'm going to try to draw.
Why is it so hard?
Do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Um...
These are the past ones.
Can I...
Can I go backwards?
Does it work like that?
I didn't give you his legs.
Oh, sugar.
Yeah!
Um...
I hope Ace is somewhere there.
This is gonna...
I don't even know what I drew.
No idea.
I can't tell what those are.
What is that?
Okay.
I spelled that all wrong.
No, I didn't get it.
What the fuck?
Uh...
What?
What does that even mean?
Um, shit.
That is not even me.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Fuck.
I don't know what else to draw.
That's exactly what I drew, I think.
Is this a vine reference?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Locked in.
I locked in.
Did I give...
Wait, did I give them bodies?
I don't think I gave them bodies.
I don't even know where they are.
I don't know.
There's a shot in the dark.
Mercy, you know what that is gonna be interpreted as.
And will I stop the creative flow?
Oh my god.
Do you stop the creative flow?
Amy's got a hoodie here.
Oh, sugar.
I put juice on her.
This is hard.
I didn't even know what the fuck I'm doing anymore.
I'm fucking dying.
What is this?
What is happening?
Someone had a stroke.
Could you ever do this one?
Hope you're feeling okay.
Make sure you hydrate.
Fuck, I didn't have enough time to write it.
Oh man.
How do I even draw this?
This is...
Mm-hmm.
That's the tongue.
And then this is...
literally everyone.
Wait.
I don't know.
Okay, then what...
I don't know where the body is.
What am I drawing?
Oh.
I...
Motion swipes as well.
And a little arrow to indicate which...
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
I think I drew it correctly.
A little bit of lipstick.
Ah, where is it?
Cute? I don't know.
I just drew anything.
I don't know.
Oh, she's sad.
No, my hair.
I can't wait to see the end of this.
This is going to be...
This is a great...
This is going to be fucking insane.
What's going on in the ceiling?
Oh, I need to draw on the ceiling quick.
There we go.
Oh, I'm so scared of what these look like.
Me too.
I can't read.
It's the end of the TikTok.
Oh, my God.
I think she's beautiful.
I was like...
Oh, you're not okay.
I completely missed the body.
Oh, my God.
Don't talk to my face.
I was going to...
I was going to write even being cute.
She was on a stick.
I'm so dating.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, that's why you were home in Indiana Jones.
I was like, where did that come from?
I was trying to write Cowboy,
but I didn't.
Oh, that's so adorable.
I got so mad.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
You're talking to me.
I'm sorry.
Wait, why is he crying?
Your eye is gone.
It's gone white.
It's gone purple.
I love colors.
It really was cooked.
I used the color black
and I used red as well
and orange.
What is going on with him?
That's so rude.
He's loving.
He's so dead.
I can't breathe.
This was beautiful.
Hey.
I like this girl.
Oh.
He's like,
what is going on?
I don't know.
You're so fucking eraser.
That's why you're so cute.
You're so cute.
How did we get back to boobs?
I don't know how you ran into that.
Obviously.
Well, actually, that potato was really bad.
Never mind.
Aw.
Awesome.
You'll learn number one.
Wait, I don't know.
You'll learn number three.
You're so cute.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Stop.
Oh no.
Look at his soul.
What's happening in the middle of the world?
Oh my god.
The book got you this.
Oh, they drew us?
Yes.
Your mom called me.
No!
Oh no!
What are you doing?
Oh my god!
What keeps her from smiling?
Same.
My jaw hurt.
Okay, okay.
Oh no!
Okay!
Oh my god!
Can somebody download that one?
That's so amazing!
That's so fucking funny!
I love it!
They got the premium pass!
You see at the convention.
They got the premium pass.
That's funny!
I'm tying Amy to the tracks.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I'm not going to endure the girls to anything more.
Because our faces are ready to fall off after that.
Is anyone doing a stream?
Is anyone putting?
Are you doing a stream right away, Isnora?
Because I'll do something.
I need to appear really bad.
I'm going to jump out of the call.
Of course, you need to pee.
I'm asking my new piss out!
I know!
I'm going to jump out of the call
and do a little zart so then I'll redirect into you, Isnora.
I'm going to jump out of the call and do a little zart so then I'll redirect into you, Isnora.
Okay?
I'm going to be on start though.
Okay, right.
I might play, do you guys want me to?
I might play some Call of the Lamb.
If someone does a pop-up stream just tell me.
I'll talk to my refunds for a bit.
Thank you so so much all members and dolls
for this hilarity that ensued
after such a miserable start.
That's amazing.
Such a miserable start to power water.
I always shat myself from laughing so hard.
Oh my god.
We already know AC's panties are soaked.
So let's not...
Am I probably?
No!
No.
Alright, let me sniff.
Let me sniff test.
No! Don't do the sniff test!
Rather pungent my dear.
You have to take a test.
Taste instead.
She just disintegrated.
Oh my god.
Great.
I'm going to jump out of chat.
Thank you so much.
I'll see you guys next week with each other.
So look out for that.
I'll jump out of chat.
Thank you so much my darlings, my daughters, my girls.
I'll talk to you very shortly.
I'm off to the refunds.
I love you my daughters.
These are the Villalor girls.
Yeah.
They're so cute, right?
Oh my god.
That was really something.
Okay, wait.
Are you guys still streaming?
Yeah.
I am.
I don't know what to do.
I guess I got to go off.
Okay, let's go off.
Go to just chatting and then raid into Azra.
I think Azra's next, right?
Yeah.
Me and Azra are going to be streaming.
She's doing Stardew.
I'm doing Call of the Limb.
Wait, wait.
So Shibi and Azra are going to stream right now?
Yeah, I'm going to keep streaming.
No.
I'm probably going to end this one
so that the bot is separated.
Oh, yeah.
I ended it to make a new one.
Okay.
I'll hang up and then I'll go to the
just chatting and then I'll send.
I'll check if y'all ready.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
I don't know why my chat isn't working.
I've double triple-checked it.
I'm so sorry.
My darling.
Snippets.
My senpai.
That we were going to play,
as you know, we were going to play
Power Wash Simulator
except
isn't, because you had to redo the room.
You're probably right.
Yeah, you're probably right.
And what happened with
Power Wash Simulator
is that every time
it got past four people
it just disconnected
and would not connect
everyone in, even though we were in a room
for six players.
And then that was
and then we couldn't
we tried. We tried over and over
and over and over again and we're like
stop, stop moving, stop moving.
Maybe they'll come in if we stop moving
and it didn't work. And so instead
we
we ended up having
to pick something
really fast. So we went through
a list of games. We're like
do you have this? No. Do you have this? No.
Do you have this? No. Oh shit.
How about we do Jackbox? Oh shit. How do you stream
Jackbox? We don't know how to stream Jackbox.
All of us can't stream
Jackbox. What do we have instead? Oh,
we have Gartik Phone. That's free.
And so we stayed
with Gartik Phone instead.
So I apologize
for the fact that we did not do
PowerWash Simulator
because it was like
if I knew everyone was going to go
like balls to the walls
like
yeah, I wouldn't have
tried to save the stream.
I didn't have to try to save it
but I ended up
as far as a train
wreck. It's far from the moon.
This ball is going to go away.
Probably.
I'll see if it stays up but it might go away.
I never stood a chance.
I never stood a chance. I was like
oh man.
It's okay. Can you
see how
how like
gosh, we're so friendly with each
other. It's so funny.
It's so funny.
I'm sorry. Also earlier
when you heard like the weird sounds, I'm so
sorry. I literally laughed so hard.
I
the my T went out my nose.
Everyone's so cute together. I know
they're so cute, right?
I love them so much.
Honestly, we
we're very
off the walls with each other.
We're off the walls to each other.
My stomach hurts
so badly.
The side of my ears
are hurting from my headphones
from laughing so hard.
Very wholesome.
I missed the
tear of the day. I think it's green tea.
I think it's just a regular green tea.
It really
unfortunately
my arm
is still really, really, really bad.
It's less bad than before, but now
it's all like bumpy and gross.
So
I'm gonna go rest again in order
for it to calm down. I sent
pictures to the girls and they were like,
oh geez, are you gonna be okay for
today's stream? And I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah, it'll be fine.
Someone said you were snorting matcha. I mean, like
it's probably green tea. So yeah,
what is green tea? It's matcha.
Was an allergic reaction? I think it's an
allergic reaction.
I think it's an allergic
reaction.
But it's like, I felt it last night.
It crawled.
Like the rash went all the way to my back
and I was like,
what's going on?
So I changed shirts and everything. I changed
shirts.
I changed shirts.
I'm gonna see if by
Saturday,
if by Saturday, if it doesn't go away,
I'm gonna go to the doctor because
it is like
more than half
down now. It's like,
it's no long, it's still red
ish. It's pink. It's more pink than red
and less bumpy.
So it should
be fine.
It should be fine. I'm looking at my arm right now.
You should invest in EpiPen for sure though.
I was gonna drink
some Benadryl, but Benadryl makes me really
sleepy and I didn't want to take it before
the stream.
It's improving.
I put some Vaseline on it
to soothe it, to soothe it.
Have you tried taking
Benadryl while showering?
Is that supposed to be like some kind of
innuendo thing?
Are you gonna take it now? Yeah, after stream,
right now.
I know that Benadryl
is supposed to be
what do you call it?
It's supposed to make people sleepy and in Japan
it's marketed as a sleeping
aid, but
a lot of my friends
don't feel the sleepy effect from it.
They're like, oh.
They're like, oh, it's
it makes me actually quite awake
and I was like, damn, now
it makes me sleepy. So I'm gonna drink
some, I'm gonna take some
and then we're gonna see if this rash goes down
so we can
maybe have a good time.
Tomorrow, I believe, is Harvester.
Let's go over my schedule again.
Where's my schedule?
There it is.
Tomorrow is
Harvester
part two.
So we'll have a lot of
fun with that.
Um
and then
after after that Saturday
is my day off and then Sunday
we're back at it with an unarchived
karaoke stream.
So we'll be singing
some songs.
We'll be
humming some haas.
Yeah, so
that's it.
Remember, this is
since I woke up early for the club
Harvester
and the unarchived
karaoke stream will be at
my regular times at 11pm
EDT.
So we're gonna
we're gonna have a good time.
Hopefully I'm really looking forward
to Harvester. Maybe we'll finish it. Who knows.
If there's multiple endings
I might try all of them.
Who knows.
Or I might keep one ending.
That might be the case.
But yeah, I'm looking forward to
the rest of the week and then the following week
when the following week will be
much less streams
and I probably need that dang rest.
I need that dang rest.
So thank you
for the stream. I hope
this was okay for some
EU, EU bros.
I'm sorry that a lot of people can't catch my streams.
You know how far through
you got last time? No idea.
No idea. We're on our third
third thingy.
So I'm probably gonna take a rest next week
and then recharge myself
again and slowly
put my streams back to
five streams a week.
So
let's get my thingy
out. My stream thingy
out. Where's my room?
Where's my room? Room?
My live room!
My live room and then
we'll raid into
one of the girls
in one of the
third.
So let's see.
I'll send you guys
into Azura
Azura Dulays
stream
because I think she's starting
starting Stardew Valley.
Yeah.
Unless she sings for like
hours again then yeah.
I'm gonna go back to sleep.
I'm gonna
maybe put an ice pack on my
hives rash again.
So thank you so much everyone
for today. I know it's chaotic
and I'm very sorry
that you waited a long time
due to technical difficulties
but I'm hoping to see you all
tomorrow or another time very soon.
Okay.
And that's, let's go!
Scream for Mercy!
Thanks for watching!